a deadly house fire just two weeks ago
certainly a difficult reminder of how
critical it is to practice and also
prepare your family for emergencies it
is fire prevention month Candace Charles
joining us live at the Clark County
building department Candace you've been
talking about fire extinguishers the
importance of having one but that's not
all you need good morning
good morning to you Heather that is
correct good morning folks as you can
see it's a little smoking here we got
some flanks going you don't want to wait
until this situation to come up with a
plan so I've got a fire inspector Nick
giulito with me tell me exactly what we
should be doing in a situation like this
situation like this we should have a
plan in place to where there's two
locations that you can exit your house
safely and meet your family and friends
uh when you do see smoke like this in
this environment you want to keep as low
as possible to the floor with the air is
a little bit cleaner and you want to get
out and stay out all right so we're
going to try to run this drill through
really quickly so you want to stay low
guys and then do you want to touch the
walls just in case you need to guide
somebody with the back of your hand in
case it's too hot you don't want to burn
your hand okay prep again you should be
looking for an exit here
and you should be reuniting with your
friends Stacy hello and of course as you
create this plan and what other things
should you tell your kids so that
they're prepared for the end of that
plan as well that exit don't go back in
looking for your pets your pets are
smart enough they'll probably make it
out uh just get out and stay out perfect
thank you so much Nick for chatting us
we appreciate it of course we haven't
covered with all these details so you
can look at it again and run this with
your family on our website 8newsnow.com
now from the Clark County building I'm
Candace Charles 8 news now planning is